et
c'est
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
deuxième édition de frames lime ce
nouveau rendez vous quand vous propose
avec l'équipe de fremm c'est qui aura
lieu les mardi et vendredi à 17 heures
donc le principe est très simple on
reçoit deux vidéastes et puis on discute
de choses et d'autres avec moins à la
régie le bon vince donc ce rapport sera
là pour assurer la technique virginie
est là dans le jazz pour prendre vos
questions donc n'hésitez pas pendant
l'émission a posé des questions que je
poserai moi même à nos deux invités
cette émission peut être réalisé grâce à
nos partenaires du cnc talent merci à
eux et on va commencer tout de suite
cette émission avec notre premier invité
j'ai nommé les vélos bonjour là bonjour
comment ça va ça va très bien et toi
tout se passe bien ce confinement se
passe bien les uns écoutent ce
confinement se passe plutôt bien
alors les à pour ceux qui ne te
connaîtraient pas tuer une créatrice
polyvalente c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
difficile de te mettre dans une dans une
case tu es tu et scientifique tué
vulgarisatrice tué vidéaste eu et auteur
tué beaucoup de choses donc pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas est ce que tu
peux nous retracer un petit peu ton
parcours
comment tu as commencé dans ce milieu de
la science et de la vulgarisation
alors merci effectivement oui je fais je
suis et plusieurs casquettes
j'ai commencé par faire des études de
sciences donc de géologie et de physique
j'ai fait une thèse d'ailleurs en
géophysique et puis pendant ses études
j'étais déjà très intéressé par la
vulgarisation à l'époque ça commençait
tout juste sur youtube et donc après ma
tête j'ai fait j'ai fait de la
communication scientifique
je suis en master à grenoble et
et puis je me suis lancé là dedans et
j'ai fait un stage au cnrs et parce que
je travaillais vraiment sûr sur des
choses à la frontière avec la vidéo et
les sciences on a formé le projet de
créer une chaîne de vulgarisation
scientifique qui s'appelle zeste de
sciences qui donc a été lancé un peu
plus tard
et puis bas pendant ce temps moi j'ai
continué mon petit bout de chemin j'ai
rencontré plein de gens merveilleux dont
toi patrick et qui m'ont poussé kim eux
qui m'ont donné envie de continuer là
dedans et donc maman bas je fais je
travaille un peu pour le cnrs
encore un peu sur la chaîne 2 de
sciences bientôt je vais passer le
relais je travaille avec une revue qui
s'appelle mondes sociaux pour faire des
vidéos de vulgarisation mais en sciences
humaines et sociales vulgariser toujours
des sciences mais optimisation et puis
après je fais je travaille pour
l'institut polaire suisse voilà est
toujours l'idée c'est toujours de parler
de science de façon vulgariser même si
j'ai plusieurs casquettes que ce soit
vidéo ou écrite voilà c'est un peu
stressé alors on a commencé à te voir
sur youtube sur la chaîne du cnrs xestas
de science on disait que tu as tu as
passé le relais depuis tu n'y a plus sur
cette chaîne alors j'y suis encore pour
dix ans jusqu'à la fin de l'été est là
on est en train de rechercher d'autres
personnes
pour pour animer cette chaîne donc c'est
un processus en cours mon kart
tu es parti dans d'autres aventures vous
aventure collective dont on a pu le voir
notamment dans l'excellente saison 2 du
vortex la meilleure thèse en va
évidemment je pense qu'on peut le dire
de façon assez objective donc un vortex
pour ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas cette
cette émission qui a commencé il ya à
peu près un homme et deux sacs et
coproduite par par arte donc il ya eu
une première saison nous ont participé à
la seconde saison avec notamment manon
brill et christophe d'hygiène mentale
le principe du vortex de réunir 4
vidéaste dans une maison colocation pour
qu'ils traitent des sujets ensemble
donc il ya trois sujets par vidéaste
donc on en a fait 12 et donc j'ai eu la
joie de participer avec toi est là
actuellement donc tu en train de
préparer un autre projet en
collaboration
c'est lé monde du dessous en dire plus
ouais donc c'est un projet avec théo de
la chaîne malade mental et on s'est
lancé un petit défi
on a on veut parler de l'océan et on a
décidé de d'en parler sous l'eau donc on
se lance dans la production de haut
donc minimum six épisodes comme on est
en train de faire un financement
participatif il vous reste une semaine
pour nous aider à financer le 7e et
peut-être même le huitième épisode est
donc une idée c'est de parler dans de
l'eau plus généralement pas seulement de
l'océan parce qu'on va aussi parler de
la glace et à chaque fois d'aller sur un
endroit différent qui pourra nous aider
à illustrer notre propos
et on voit on va aller depuis l'histoire
de l'exploration océanique jusqu'à leur
échappaient jusqu au réchauffement
climatique et ses effets à la fois aux
folles dans les milieux tropicaux
on va parler aussi des courants
océaniques de la biodiversité
sous-marine de comment on peut vivre
oslo et voilà on essaie de traiter pas
mal de choses et donc voilà c'est un peu
ambitieux et on remercie le cnc ouais
aussi parce qu'on a une scène c'est sur
ces projets merci le cdh c'est par
rapport à ce projet donc vous avez lancé
une campagne de financement participatif
qui a fonctionné qu'il atteint son but
là vous en êtes aux balises suivant
c'est ça donc notre but était d'arriver
à clore le budget donc cnc finances
toujours la moitié d'un projet à hauteur
de maximum la moitié d'un projet et donc
il nous fallait trouver d'autres
d'autres financements on a trouvé des
partenaires scientifiques
on a trouvé des partenaires qui nous
aident d'un point de vue technique et
puis voilà nous fallait clore le budget
avec le financement participatif c'est
fait et maintenant on s'est dit ben
voilà pour chaque chaque personne va
pouvoir nous aider à financer un nouvel
épisode est donc par chaque créneau de
10000 euros on prévoit au minimum un
épisode de plus et si on y arrive si on
a assez d'image peut-être même deux
épisodes donc là on est dans cette phase
ii du deuxième créneau
d'accord les tâches le jeu
comme pour tout le monde la situation
actuelle qu'on promet un petit peu les
plans que ce premier épisode il était
prévu pour quand bazot alors on devait
commencer le tournage en avril
donc on va répondre c'est des tournages
en prime vous apportez tout est reporté
et donc c'était prévu le 1er épisode
pour pour un pont donc voilà on la
prochaine étape de tournage se serait
jamais donc notre créneau qu'on a prévu
pour tourner mais on paraît on attend
encore de voir si cissé débloqué fin
mais si on peut partir parce que du coup
à chaque fois on filme sous l'eau et est
assez peu en france et même si c'était
en france en fait avec le confinement on
peut pas vraiment se déplacer pour ce
genre de noisy et le premier épisode
portera sur coup c'est difficile à dire
parce que on a en a reporté à la base
c'était à c'était sur le les effets du
réchauffement climatique en milieu
tropical et la biodiversité tropicale
mais voilà donc ce ne sera pas celui-là
c'est tout ce que je peux vous dire donc
je crois que ce sera peut-être sursis ce
sera peut-être sur le sur une et la
pollution des océans d'accord alors tu
as d'autres projets collectifs
tu es vraiment une créatrice qu'on
rentre souvent au sein de groupe donc
c'est le cas aussi pour avis de
recherche est ce que tu peux nous en
dire plus sur ce ce projet là qu'est ce
que c'est donc avis de recherche c'est
donc c'est la chaîne qui est qu'il
permet de vulgariser des sciences
humaines et sociales
pour le financer par le magazine sociaux
etc manon brel qui a fait les quatre
premières saisons petits ont rappelé
lundi 16 ans quand j'ai parlé disons ça
fait ça faisait presque quatre ans un
peu moins que mamour faisait des vidéos
eh oui donc je vous encourage à aller
voir
l'idée c'est de parler de recherche
chaque fois un épisode c'est la
vulgarisation d'une recherche en
sciences humaines et sociales et on va à
fouiller on cherche un peu déçu j'ai un
peu originaux donc pour par exemple
balla le prochain épisode ce sera sur
les super héroïne et c est ce que les
super héroïne se battent comme des
filles d'accord attendu que le dernier
en date il est suivi par deux jeux vidéo
ben ouais et la dernière en date et jeux
vidéo c'est capitalisme et jeux vidéo
pas tous ces messieurs on l'a fait avec
stupide economics une chaîne qui est
raide économique est vraiment super
content que je vous encourage à boire ce
que tu fais ce que tu peux nous habite
chez en quelques mots le sujet de
l'épisode on fait comment alors l'idée
c'est de regarder comment dans certains
jeux vidéo des mmorpg nous des jeux
vidéo en ligne donc avec plusieurs
joueurs on peut développer un
capitalisme sans limite et donc pour ça
on utilise deux exemples le jeu vidéo et
eve online et le très connu au world of
warcraft et enjoint au mans en fait les
concepteurs du jeu
il crée une obsolescence programmée des
notamment des armes et des choses qu on
peut on peut associer à son
à son personnage et donc on est de dire
que ça on montre que qui a vraiment des
objets qui une fois qu'ils sont portés
bas une fois qu'ils sont utilisés ton
peuple uni les revendre et les échanges
et donc ça encourage toujours et en
avoir des nouveaux voilà il y en a qui
sont associés à certains niveaux donc
c'est vraiment en fait l'idée c'est de
faire le parallèle avec avec le
capitalisme et eve online là c'est
carrément un jeu qui qui est qui a des
ressources qui sont créés par les
utilisateurs
donc là on a vraiment en modèle
économique qui est créé dans l'univers
du jeu et c'est assez fou parce que ce
jeu a pris tellement d'ampleur que
maintenant il ya aussi des économistes
chaque mois il ya en fait tout plein
d'études d'économistes qui voit et qui
essaient de comprendre comment
en fait on peut on peut créer un capital
comment réagissent les gens quand il ya
un capitalisme vraiment sans limite
c'est à dire qu'il ya pas de loi qui
encadre qui limite les échanges et et en
même temps y'a pas dead pour ceux qui se
casse la gueule voilà et puis on peut
pirater
alors il me semble que world of warcraft
a vo thi avait aussi été étudiée par
rapport à cette cette épidémie qui
s'était déclenchée tu vois ce que je
veux c'est simplement une forme comme
comme cas d'école et je crois qu'à je
suis pas dans ma vidéo et aller au café
de darty bat elodie je crois qui a fait
quoi qui est lui qui avait fait une
vidéo là dessus à vérifier mais on sent
que c'est sur la chaîne parce que pour
ceux qui ne voient pas du tout qu'on
parle dans le jeu
warcraft je crois qu'elles ont qu'il y
avait eu une série de bugs en fait qui
s'était déclenchée et c'était une forme
d'épidémie qui était pas du tout prévu
par les concepteurs du jeu et se tait
vainement avait été observé ensuite par
les chercheurs pour donc faire des
analogies entre les épidémies dans le
monde réel et l'épidémie du jeu quoi
elle va y ait vraiment des analogies sur
la responsable se répand c'était assez
impressionnant
bon alors du coup je pense que l'on
pourra en parler plus en détail avec léo
qui sera invitée de la prochaine
émission
ce sera l'occasion d'en parler il me
semble que tu travailles aussi également
enfin tu as déjà tourné les étals en
question mais pour avec la la la bnf
pour une série dé vous oui mais pas
encore sorti et bah oui justement c'est
vraiment je fais des épices d'accueil
nota bene donc c'est une série ce matin
notre rétro news passé sur la chaîne
rai3 news d'ailleurs que ce sera diffusé
normalement bientôt et unis décès de
bongo on a une liseuse de deux
d'articles et on va fouiller un peu dans
les articles de la bnf pour trouver donc
les articles de rétro news cd article
qui date depuis le début du siècle
dernier je crois c'est plus exactement
mais en gros c'est plein d'articles de
presse qui sont qui sont réunies est
donc il y avait il ya des choses très
très charmante des publicités moi je
parle de les publicités sur la
radioactivité c'est quand même fou quoi
on faisait des comités pour des pyjamas
radioactifs et certains vont mal
radioactifs contenir mon pyjama tient
chaud il peut même réchauffer mon
plateau sur lequel je peux manger
c'était presque le plus brillant non
plus donc ça ce sera donc sur la chaîne
rai tre news dans la chaîne de la bnf et
ce sera dans quelques semaines et ça va
être répartie un peu au cours du mois
d'avril
et je crois que les premiers épisodes
devraient sortir la semaine prochaine
mais à confirmer
peut-être que benjamin vous en dira plus
peut-être qu'il en sait un peu plus que
moi eh ben on verra ça avec du tout à
l'heure puisque je rappelle que la vie
belle de l'hôte a peiné nous rejoint à
partir de 17h30 alors les âges avaient
une petite question par rapport à la
situation actuelle puisque évidemment on
va aussi parler de ça quel est ton
regard de scientifiques donc de géo
l'homme en particulier sur l'impact de
la crise actuelle sur la planète on
parle beaucoup il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de d'un fou ici activités qui nous parle
voilà deux des bienfaits de l'épidémie
entre guillemets sur la nature sauvage
et merle des animaux qui reviennent la
qualité de l'air s'améliore quel est ton
on regarde au géologue là dessus alors
c'est alors je précise que je n'ai pas
prendre part à cette question je ne
cherche pas dire de bêtises et
effectivement on voit on voit des
améliorations assez impressionnantes
notamment dans l'est les gaz à effet de
serre elle est
les polluants atmosphériques et
du coup c'est un peu comme si tout le
monde s'était mis d'accord en fait d'un
coup pour sauver la planète
non mais plus on a des jeunes et celle
de tant de géologues
il faudrait que ça dure encore un peu
plus longtemps pour que ce soit visible
par contre ce qu'on peut totalement
espérer c'est que c'est que ça puisse
donner un peu une bonne lancée pour
réduire nos émissions et faire en sorte
qu'on puisse qu'on puisse retrouver
peut-être pas ce niveau de non pollution
mais en tout cas réduire un peu la
pollution au niveau géologique de moi
comme ça de diminution ça ne verra pas
justement dans un très bon épisode du
vortex on parle du fait que pour que une
chose se voit l'échelle des temps
géologiques il faut vraiment que ce soit
le est progressif et pas progressives
justement et c'est à la fois long et
rapide c'est à dire que la transition
doit faire assez lentement pour qu elle
imprègne les roches ou quoi mais elle
doit être assez grandes pour que ce soit
visible d'accord très bien et oui on
donc on parle notamment de
l'amélioration de la qualité de l'air
est aussi de l'impact que cela peut
avoir sur les animaux
donc on a vu que voilà notamment en
italie km et des dauphins qui revenaient
vers les côtes alors il y avait aussi
pas mal de fenioux cette exagération ça
mais personnellement je trouve ça
incroyable de voir que en quelques
semaines
le simple fait d'avoir freiné les
activités humaines peuvent avoir déjà
autant d'effets positifs sur la
biodiversité et sur l'environnement
quand c'est vraiment comme si ce qu'on
n'avait pas pu faire pour essayer
d'améliorer la situation de la planète
et et freiner le réchauffement
climatique
un virus finalement nous forcer à le
faire on s'aperçoit que c'est efficace
quoi est bon il ya pas mal
d'observateurs qui craignent que une
fois que tout cela sera terminé qu'une
fois le confinement sera levé ça risque
de repartir encore plus fort j'espère
qu'on va éviter ça mais après est ce que
qu'on pourrait imaginer on voit aussi
pour la pollution sonore appareil c'est
assez impressionnant mais pour reprendre
l'exemple des poissons qu'on voit enfin
dans les dents dans l'est dans les
canaux enfin les poissons je sais pas
mais en tout cas l'eau est beaucoup plus
claire dans les canaux à venise ces
bribes en fait c'est beaucoup lié au
fait que la le limouxin est déposée du
coup toute la poussière en suspension
qui est remué sans arrêt par par la
circulation de bateaux
elle sait tout déposer au fond des
canaux à venise comme ça ça pourrait
être trouvée si on disait par exemple
que un week-end par mois pendant deux
jours il ya plus de circulation
alors ça ferait flamber très pas mal de
gens mais ça pourrait permettre de
week-ends par mois au revoir l'eau
claire je vous remercie
j'ai une amie qui qui a eu cette
observation la cie par exemple
maintenant qu'on a vu ce que c'était
parce que là on vit quelque chose
d'unique en tout cas de notre vivant
mais j'avais vécu un truc pareil
maintenant qu'on sait ce que c'est
maintenant qu'on sait ce qu'est un
confinement est ce que en tant que
société en tant que civilisation est ce
qu'on pourrait pas essayer de mettre en
place des pauses qui seraient préparées
à l'avancé
j'en ai hockey tels semaine on fait une
pause on laisse un petit peu la nature
sera générée plus on repart donc
maintenant qu'on a testé avec on voit un
peu comment on peut s'en sortir
ce serait intéressant de faire des
pauses organisé pour passer je pense que
par après et je sais pas si tous très
motivés pauvres est à ce point là en
tout cas mais là je parlais de la
pollution sonore à paris c'est assez
impressionnant on peut se dire qu'enfin
boîte ça me dérangerait vraiment pas de
nous dire que pendant une journée
ben il ya effectivement on pas pas
forcément se confiner dans le sens où
l'on pourra pas du tout sentir est allé
voir les jours mais au moins pas pas du
tout prendre la voiture pas de tous
contre les scooters et on aurait on
pourrait concourir à entendre les
oiseaux et refaire c'est clair alors là
une question
le saïan stoner qui nous disent eh bah
c'est long pour laisser une marque sur
la glace je suppose entre parenthèses
antarctique le fait qu' il y ait cette
pause de l'humanité lettre de hu est
alors deux mois c'est pas assez bon pour
la glace non plus il faudrait que en
fait pour la glace il faut le temps que
la glace se forme de moi ça doit être ça
ne veut pas dire de bêtises mais il ne
semble pas que ce soit assez pour pour
qu'il ya une formation de la sas est
assez grande je crois que c'est à peu
près on augmente on doit augmenter de 6
remarque ça d'être quelques centimètres
par mois peut-être que ce sera l'une des
mois qu'est que l'avenir nous le dira
alors on va passer aux recommandations
culturel les uns est ce que tu as les
conseils pour que donc nos amis puissent
vivre un confinement plus agréable donc
série fille il me livre jeu de quad ou
alors belle jusqu'à ce qu'on fait quand
on parle de ce type de questionnement
j'ai vu une série qui s'appelle green
blood greenwood winblad thomas green's
où c'est une série de documentaires ça
change un peu des séries c'est une série
de documentaires etc sur france tv
je sais plus froch lequel france nous
prendre cinq ans tv sur le site français
vous pouvez le retrouver
donc c'est une série de quatre épisodes
quoi et c'est super intéressant c'est
sur les des journalistes
c'est un groupe de journalistes qui a
repris donc ses sorties par écrit
l'année dernière l'été dernier c'est un
groupe de journalistes qui a décidé de
recherche temps de reprendre les les
recherches de certains journalistes qui
ne pouvait plus travailler parce qu'il
était menacé
et à chaque fois ce que des enquêtes sur
des projets liés à
à l'exploitation minière souvent donc ça
va être l'exploitation du sable ou des
minerais
voilà et donc il ya l'inde le guatemala
il y a juste il plus qu'elle il ya la
tanzanie et je sais il y en a au moins
trois ont mes souvenirs et donc c'est
ensuite voilà donc ça c'est pas très
joyeux voilà mais c'est super
intéressant comme comme questionnement
et voilà alors on vous met le lien dans
le chat vert projet gameblog vers 6h
génie qui a donc placé le lien dans le
tchat
ok donc ça c'est une série documentaire
qui passe vous avez sur france télé
ouais alors qu'est ce que c'est super au
niveau réalisé comme film alors
récemment j'ai vu un film qui s'appelle
just merci mais je pense qu'il était
chargé
sinon à 8,6 âgées une série peut-être
vous l'avez déjà vu mais que j'adore ces
feedbacks des meilleurs ça je vous avais
deux saisons si vous l'avez pas déjà vu
alors ça passe sur amazon prime ouais
bah c'est que tu peux nous fait un petit
peu l'histoire le concept font fait du
rap ikea s'est ensuite l'histoire d'une
jeune femme d'une trentaine d'années qui
alors pour pas spoiler c'est compliqué
qui
et on suit les personnages qui sont
autour d'elle et c'est avec un humour
très assez sarcastique et quelques
regards caméra il ya vraiment une
connivence qu'il crée ce quatrième heure
qui est complètement brisée et puis
l'humour est vraiment je dirais donc
vins français soit effectivement c'est
plus trash plus incisif et c'est très
bien écrit c'est très drôle et épuisent
à une série qui a une fin et on accepte
enfin moi je n'étais content que qu'est
une vraie fin et que voilà c'est ce qui
fait le charme que c'est une écriture
comme si c'était un film bien mais c'est
vrai que la comédienne qui porte déjà
oublié son nom malheureusement qu'il est
aussi qui a écrit et donc il est le
personnage principal de la série porte
cette série à bout de bras et
l'exceptionnel et comme tu disais il ya
beaucoup de regards caméra beaucoup de
ruptures du quatrième mur s adressent à
nouveau permanence et effectivement
c'est drôle c'est bien joué c'est
surprenant
c'est vraiment une super série douala
flic bague on va on va vous l'écrire
dans le dans le chat aussi donc c'est à
b à g et donc c'est sûr un sur amazon
prime bourguiba et h au château
ok ils ont fait une adaptation en
français mais je conseille vraiment la
regardant ces mouches quelque chose
comme ça alors là que l'actrice donc
s'appelle phoebe waller bridge est elle
exceptionnelle
est-ce que tu as d'autres
recommandations pour nous les a défiés
vivre mais je sais pas vous mais à ou
alors moi je vais chez tf1 des deux des
trucs qui m'ont inventé triste pendant
ce confinement c'est qu'elle est là et
plein de spectacles c'est vraiment la
saison belle
normalement je vais voir des concerts
des débats les j'aime beaucoup aller
voir
de la danse et donc il ya plein de trucs
qui ont été annulés et l'opéra de paris
si vous voulez regarder il ya le père
apparaît qu'il fait des qui fait d en
fait qui reprend certes mais de certains
balle est filmé en ligne donc voilà si
vous aimez les balais alors moi je suis
plus danse contemporaine maisons n'ont
pas encore mis j'attends sa patience
beaucoup plus au théâtre et magie
beaucoup de pièces d'étape qui ont été
filmés quand même joué et filmé et lors
du coulage et balayant en tête pour pour
aller regarder il ya la mk2 qui fait la
mk2 qui est ensemble de signer à paris
et en régions aussi je crois et donc
l'appareil
ils ont pas mal de conférences
scientifiques et ils ont des aussi des
balais et des opéras donc je crois
qu'ils sont en train d'ouvrir leur leur
truc en ligne voilà sinon en livre si
bas après c'est j'ai un mur un livre qui
m'a beaucoup mieux cette année que je
conseille de lire qui est intéressant
mais ouais sortir
mouchoirs c'est ça s'appelle n'y suis
pas de larmes sans gants et alors c'est
un c'est un bouquin qui parle qui se
passe au en suède au moment de
l'explosion de l'épidémie du sida
enfin donc le duvet et à l'arrivée de
ceux de ce virus est en fait ça parle
beaucoup ces racontée du point de vue de
quelqu'un de la communauté homosexuelle
à l'époque qui est témoin de jéhovah est
en fait donc ça suit deux choses en
parallèle ça suit lui sa découverte de
cumuler 2 2 donc le comment il gère ça
par rapport à ses croyances et à tout ça
ça et en parallèle sa board aussi
comment tout lasse toute la sphère
médiatique a parlé de cette de cette
épidémie comme ans et franchement ça
donne une toute autre idée de la suède
qui se disait à l'époque
et donc c'est très très source est ce
qu'un que c'est une histoire c'est un
roman c'est ça
mais tout ce qui traite enfin il ya des
extraits de temps en temps il ya les
extraits de journaux qui sont des vrais
extraits de journaux quoique que les
gens lisent voilà il ya toute une
galerie de personnages aux plages eux
via dit le personnage principal et son
copain qui sont les deux personnages
principaux on va dire et puis tu as
toute une galerie de personnages donc
c'est un peu gros seins il est vraiment
voila voila il m'a un peu bouleversé et
surtout j'ai trouvé ça super intéressant
la façon dont des coûts comment on parle
comment les médias peuvent parler de
quelque chose quand on n'a pas la
connaissance de l'origine
de la maladie on ne sait pas pourquoi et
donc ça ça heurte énormément tabou en
plus donc c'est super compliqué d'en
parler donc tu nous as dit déçu pas tes
larmes sans gants csn ne suis pas de
larmes sans gants façon je crois pas le
jeu c'est ça ouais qu'est ce que je veux
dire il en reste une minute les avants
devront trouver le bon ben on nous a
demandé ce que tu faisais pour répéter
journée pendant leur confinement j'ai vu
que tu faisais des puzzles pas mal ouais
c'est déposait je fais à manger des bons
trucs et puis j'ai fini un épisode on a
en fait le cnrs m'a contacté pour faire
un épisode veut un peu en mode combiné
donc de les filmer un truc chez moi
alors je continue à affirmer à écrire
des épisodes pour invite des recherches
donc finalement je vais manquer et je
vais bien merci merci beaucoup l'oea
pour ta présence des recommandations et
donc je précise que toutes les oeuvres
que tu nous as cités seront disponibles
en description du live qui sera
rediffusé en replay merci les uns très
bien merci chers aux avis si vous nous
rejoignez en cours de route
donc c'est le frames là il reçoit deux
vidéastes dans cette émission il ya deux
parties d'une demi-heure et donc pour la
deuxième partie nous allons recevoir
lamy benjamin brio de la chaîne nota
bene d'ailleurs je les invite à faire un
petit tweet pour alerter sa superbe
communauté ben je ne sais pas si tu es
si tu m'entends
on le voit là est ce que tu veux alerter
la communauté celle de m mais j'ai posté
par tous mais il est magnifique
alors comment va être plus ben comment
se passe ce confinement pourquoi écoute
ça va j'ai installé mon bureau à la cave
pour être tranquille mais mais voilà
tout se passe bien j'en profite pour
pour geek est un petit peu plus que
d'habitude
voilà parce que bon c'est vrai qu'en
terme de boulot faut prendre un rythme
aussi mais ouais c'est pas plus mal ça
me force à prendre un petit peu de de
repos sur mon clavier alors
ben présente plus bien sûr tu es devenu
la figure de l'histoire sur internet et
tu es multicasquettes toi aussi puisque
il y a des jours où c'est intéressant ce
bruit il y a des livres efficace et
c'est qu' il ya des bd il y à des vidéos
il y a beaucoup de choses et d'ailleurs
tu continue malgré la situer à poster
régulièrement des vidéos sur ta chaise
comment ça se passe dans cette situation
alors comment ça se passe
bah ça se passe que j'ai la chance moi
vue là la taille de nota bene
aujourd'hui d'avoir des gens qui
travaillent avec moi donc on est on est
plusieurs et on essaye de prendre un
maximum d'avant ce pour éviter de se
retrouver en flux tendu et puis de
galérer à sortir au dernier moment une
vidéo etc
donc on a on a un petit peu de
provisions on va dire d'avant ce donc là
la chance qu'on a pour cette période de
confinement c'est que les épisodes sont
déjà prêts pour pour avril en fait il ya
déjà une programmation moi je suis
quelqu'un d'extrêmement organisé et donc
j'ai un petit document excel avec la
liste de tous les sujets avec toutes les
colonnes avec marc et écriture qu'être
en un jeu qui offre qu'elle diffuse
donat et donc je sais exactement quel
épisode va sortir le lâcher des dates
par exemple enfin en descendant tu vois
je sais ce qui va sortir le 21 décembre
2020 dommage
tellement impressionné par son
organisation c'est vraiment une belle
entreprise de la fermette quoi c'est les
entreprises de l'histoire après voilà
après le mois ce qui est ce qui est cool
c'est qu'aujourd'hui je travaille avec
avec des auteurs qui sont formidables
moi je m'amuse à travailler sur plein de
projets différents deux sujets
différents de rencontrer des gens c'est
ça que je kiffe fois et et lamont par
exemple lundi on va
on va explorer les sociétés secrètes
donc on va aller du côté des francs
maçons des illuminati etc
mais sous le prisme de l'histoire sera
pas du tout dans le versant complotistes
de la chose on va être très terre à
terre et voilà c'est assez drôle et puis
juste après on va passer sur un format
où on va aller faire un peu de
généalogie on va aller fouiller dans des
archives de presse
après on va du côté de la chine et puis
ensuite on va faire un nuit une émission
sur les bretons pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale donc on a des vraiment
des sujets qui sont hyper derrière la
semaine la nation l'avantagent de quatre
thématiques c'est que s'est sans limite
à 7 sans limite
c'est sans limite c'est on peut on peut
vraiment parler de tout et c'est pour ça
aussi que bon vous l'avez peut-être
remarqué pour ceux qui suivent la chaîne
il ya pas mal de sponsors aussi qui a
permettent de dégager d'études pour la
chaîne et donc de payer tout le monde ce
qui est plutôt cool et des fois j'ai des
sponsors qui se sont assez inattendu
c'est à dire qu'à la fin de l'année
dernière chez moi j'avais été contacté
par aux farines sponso tour de la
conserve
quand ils me contacter je me suis dit
moi je n'avais pas eu c'est la belle
histoire de la conserve et c'était c'est
hyper intéressant oui mais à partir du
moment où ils respect historique
ça rentre dans le cadre de telles lignes
m en fait tu peux pas mais ça sent seul
historique ouais puis enfin tout et tout
est prétexte à histoire l'histoire c'est
la société donc un moment donné on peut
vraiment parler de tout et on peut faire
l'histoire des sciences en plein
d'histoire de l'art on peut en faire de
l'histoire d'un tueur alors d'ailleurs
sur la chaîne il ya combien de séries
précise est ce que tu te ranger épisode
dans des cases précises ou pas vraiment
tu fais un peu les choses comme ces
choses serre que pendant longtemps gelé
je les fais j'avais des formats amant
qui pour moi était très identifiée et
puis assez régulièrement j'ai des gens
qui venaient me voir en disant tu sais
ben je moi je fais pas la différence
entre des formats ce qui m'a dit tu vas
beaucoup frustré parce que moi je
faisais très attention à respecter un
code pour chaque format donc tu en fait
tous les épisodes on va dire podcast à
la maison je sais regroupés sous la même
bannière nota bene
voilà et après j'ai dû manger une
playlist reportage où là je vais sur le
terrain puisque c'est une partie de mon
activité de ce que j'aime faire aussi
c'est d'aller directement sur des lieux
de patrimoine ou pour aller filmer
j'ai une playlist qui est bien
identifiée c'est celle de la mythologie
puisque je reviens sur des épisodes
mythologie on a fait la mythologie
égyptienne grecque nordique chinoise ya
pas très longtemps le but c'est
d'essayer de faire des épisodes un peu
costaud de synthèse pour essayer de
comprendre un petit peu façon globale et
non exhaustive qu'engagé cette
mythologie et puis on a un format aussi
qui marche très bien que celui de motion
vers ceux-ci story ou là en gros je
tisse des parallèles entre des oeuvres
de fiction ça peut être des jeux vidéos
ou des films et puis l'histoire et ça
c'est vraiment chouette on l'a fait pour
star wars pour harry potter point plein
truc quoi ok alors on a deux questions
du chat
1re - est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
davantage de vidéos qui ne parlent pas
d'histoire voilà je savais pas qu'il ya
des vidéos qui ne parlait pas
d'histoires sur la chaîne est ce que tu
vois à quoi fait allusion ni leeds je
sais pas alors du coup tu vas en place
est-il d'accord parce que 1 en tout cas
pour ce qui est de ne pas parler
d'histoire j'avoue que j'y réfléchissais
hier soir justement où je lisais un
article et je me suis dit mais c'est pas
de l'histoire mais j'ai trop trop envie
d'en j'aimerais trop en parler sur la
chaîne est bon du coup j'ai envoyé le
jean voyez le lien à aller au peut-être
que ça pourra l'intéressé c'est le fait
que à cause du confinement de trois
milliards d'êtres humains a priori le
bruit sismique sous la terre a
grandement diminué
et voilà et adopte tous les
observatoires sismique dans le monde qui
disent devrait on a en main des relevés
qui disent qu effectivement il ya
beaucoup moins de bruit sous terre quoi
parce que les trois hommes trois
milliards d'humains sont confinés et
j'ai trouvé ça tellement incroyable que
je m'étais dit tiens et si si pourquoi
pas je faisais autre chose
mais voilà c'est pas exclu qu'un jour je
pose autre chose sur nota bene j'en sais
rien pour l'instant
j'ai tellement à faire déjà avec
l'histoire honnêtement que je vais me
limiter à ça
comme on le disait c'est vraiment sans
limite
que ladd a de la marge deuxième question
est ce qu une deuxième vidéo sur les
vikings est prévu alors il y en a eu
plusieurs
y'en a pas eu qu'une pour l'instant j'ai
pas de vidéo de prévu spéciale dédiée
aux vikings
en revanche j'avais fait une super vidéo
avec le à l'époque s'appelait le
cartographe maintenant elle s'appelle
l'histoire par les cartes vous allez sur
youtube
on avait fait un truc sur l'âge d'or des
vikings et donc c'est vraiment
l'histoire de l'âge d'or de vikings par
les cartes donc avec les cartographies
et tous et c'est vraiment super bien
donc n'hésitez pas à aller faire un
petit tour là dessus et pour rebondir
sur ce qu'ils avaient vu juste avant les
reportages in situ va y en avoir encore
bien évidemment mais pour le coup un peu
comme aller à tout à l'heure bayal assez
décalé pour l'instant on ne peut pas
aller tourner moi je devais tourner
quatre reportages au mois d'avril à bon
bah c'est des trucs qui sont qui sont
décalées
je ne sais pas quand mais l'entente
casque rigide ce qu'il sait que c'est
pas annuler ce et reporter alors pour
assurer les gens de la communauté qui
nous écoutent combien d'épisodes reste à
venir sur la chaîne qui sont déjà
tournés et qui vont pouvoir être diffusé
1 combien en stock un bon stock maire à
temps parce que si je regarde ce que
j'ai actuellement de claude et sur la
chaîne qui n'est pas passé en ligne
parce que j'ai pris un peu d'avancé
j'en ai un j'en ai 2 3 4 à 5 janvier si
cela qu'ils sont eux claude et ça veut
dire que tu as normalement de quoi tenir
pour tous le confinement là à oui de
toute façon les pieds on continue de se
dire que là j'en ai j'en ai un qui en
montage j'en ai deux autres que je dois
tourner cette cette semaine avec eux
donc a pas de souci on va on va
continuer à alimenter la chaîne voilà
c'est sûr que le confinement fait que
il faut revoir un peu certaines
méthodologies de travail et puis surtout
on est on est pas au autant au taquet
que normalement en fin mais moi j'ai dit
à mes gars voilà si si jamais vous
n'êtes pas à fond un jour ce que vous
n'avez pas le moral ce qui est normal
dans ces périodes là voilà fort sait pas
quand on s'en fout on y va à notre
rythme la halle avantage c'est qu'on
avait pris un petit peu d'avancé donc on
peut se permettre d'y aller plus
tranquille quoi donc
donc il va y avoir des épisodes de prévu
voilà c'est ses couleurs là rien que le
mois d'avril je crois que c'est sans
doute peut-être un des mots il y aura le
plus d'épisodes c'était pas prévu avant
il y en a en comptant celui qui a été
diffusée la 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 épisodes voilà
d'accord donc que les fans se rassurent
il ya de la marge
alors petite question de alban dans le
tchat
benjamin est ce que c'est toi qui as
pouces et aux pauvres à revenir tu fais
dans le générique alors c'est pas moi
qui du tout qu'il est poussé à revenir
c'est à dire que cali j'avais très envie
depuis longtemps de reprendre ce format
là en revanche elle a besoin d'un petit
coup de pouce juste d'un point de vue
technique pour fignoler les montages à
la fin est en fait c'est elle qui fait
une grosse partie du montage et où moi
j'arrive juste à la fin je fais quelques
petits trucs de mx voilà je retouche nos
deux images et puis c'est tout quoi donc
je l'aide d'un petit peu un petit peu
sur les taux power mais c'est vraiment
elle qui a repris les rênes du projet et
elle travaille donc avec un binôme
hélène au carré et ça se passe plus au
rite très bien ils sont très contentes
toutes les deux et elle espère que voilà
que ça va décoller cette année d'accord
n'hésitez pas à continuer à poser vos
questions dans le tchat
moi je les reçois et je les transmets à
l'ami ben moi j'ai une petite question
perso donc tu nous a expliqué que je
vois des épisodes en avance parce que
tout ça est préparée bien en amont mais
est-ce que la tepa tenter justement de
faire un épisode lié à l'actualité et
nous parler par exemple de l'histoire
des pandémies qui est vraiment sujet est
passionnant
ouais alors c'est clair j'ai eu ce
questionnement en là quand tout ça
commence à être très médiatisé et qu'on
a annoncé le confinement qu'on s'est
retrouvés tous là dedans je me suis dit
est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse quelque
chose
tout de suite j'ai vu des copains qui se
sont lancés dans des épisodes sur la
grippe espagnole des choses comme ça moi
je n'avais pas très envie c'est à dire
que dès le début je me suis dit bon là
tout ça est un peu en dessous gêne et je
me suis dit c'est quoi le mieux est ce
qu'il faut s'emparer du sujet essayé de
faire un peu de pédagogie autour
est-ce qu'il faut que je continue ma
programmation toute façon tout à fait
normale pour que les gens aient quelques
minutes par semaine où il s'évade est
vraiment ils pensent à autre chose et
moi je suis parti là dessus maintenant
ça me ça m'empêche pas de me dire peut
être un moment donné que je vais avoir
quelque chose à dire est que et que je
vais le faire mais j'avais pas envie
même ne serait-ce que pour moi là je
travaille toujours sur des sujets que
j'aime bien et c mais tout ça est quand
même très anxiogène et je me suis dit
est-ce que moi même j'ai envie alors que
toute la journée je n'arrête pas d'y
penser en boucle de me remettre dedans
avec le taf
je ne sais pas et puis il ya ceux il ya
ce côté
et pour le coup je suis pas sûr du tout
d'avoir la bonne réponse si tu veux mais
moi sur les deux premières semaines de
confinement là
j'ai eu un gros coup de blues en me
disant merde mon teint mon métier est
totalement inutile
quand je vois tous ces gens qui galèrent
dehors allez les caissières les deux sur
les transports sur les médecins veulent
faire les médecins les infirmières tout
le personnel médical et je me suis dit
mais mon activité futile quoi et j'ai
vraiment une
tu vois un truc où j'étais j'étais pas
bien je me suis dit que fait rage aux
kits avec léo qu'il disait mais non il
fait notre métier a jamais été heureux
autant utile qu'en ces temps là
justement pour essayer de changer un peu
les idées aux gens de faire de la
pédagogie la vulgarisation c'est
vachement important et je pense qu'il a
raison aussi c'est une question de
ressenti et je navigue encore entre ces
deux os de me dire voilà ce qu'il faut
se détacher absolument de tout ça ou
est-ce qu'il faut justement bas
l'embrasser et puis du coup essayez de
regarder la chose quoi moi mois de
janvier j'avais déjà fait un gros
épisodes sur la peste qui du coup a
bondi un petit peu donc voilà mais je
m'interdis pas de de l'aborder amendes
et même pas par rapport à ça
personnellement mon idée sur la question
c'est que il ya d'une part les chose de
vital qui nous permet de survivre
je pense aux gens qui travaillent dans
les supermarchés je pense évidemment aux
personnels soignants je pense aux aux
camionneurs je conçois ses joueurs donc
ça c'est de la survie c'est à dire qu'on
ne pourrait pas tenir sans ça mais de
l'autre côté il ya ceux qui nous aident
à vivre mon badge rire mais à vivre
parce que si les gens qui confine
actuellement sans art son film sans
musique sans jeux sont culture ce serait
infernale donc moi je sais ce que vois
ce que tu fais est ce que font beaucoup
d'autres créateurs c'est tout sauf
punitive au contraire je crois qu'en ce
moment c'est parce qu'aussi vital que de
se nourrir quoi vraiment de pouvoir
occuper son esprit ce que ça peut rendre
un peu un peu dingo ouais je suis
d'accord à matthews s'est juste aussi
peut-être le la sensation d'être un peu
privilégié tu vois pas ce que c'est vrai
que bats toi et moi on fait du
télétravail aussi en dehors de tout ça
et moi ça me donne un peu ce sentiment
où tu dis
ah ouais peut-être que j'aimerais faire
quelque chose de plus concret je ne sais
pas enfin c'est un ressenti qui est très
floue pour moi meilleur hockey moi je
pense que tu fais beaucoup de bien avec
ce que tu fais de lits sincèrement c'est
valable dans tous les cas il ya une
telle émulation de la part des créateurs
qui propose des choses que ce soit des
concerts que ce soit les conférences que
ce soit parfois des oeuvres mises à
disposition comme des doux qui a mis son
spectacle gratuit sur youtube ben voilà
tout ça ça permet aux gens de passer le
temps qu un sens se morfond ou sans
s'apitoyer sur son sort on peut penser à
autre chose le temps d'un spectacle ou
de blain c'est vrai on est tombés
d'accord je te parler de cette histoire
de l'épidémie à travers à travers
l'histoire parce que j'ai lu un article
récemment donc d'un historien qui
parlait de ça et qui parlait notamment
des comportements parce que on a
toujours ce biais face aux événements de
se dire que les comportements sont
propres à l'époque là par exemple il ya
des gens qui peuvent avoir des
comportements très discutable on a vu
des trucs insupportable comme les gens
qui ont quitté des vivres ou alors pire
le matériel médical dans les voitures
des infirmières parfois on si cette
époque est pourri c'est foutu il n'y a
plus d'espoir mais on s'aperçoit si on
observe histoire pour moi c'est des
fonctions majeures de l'histoire c'est
de pouvoir prendre du recul par rapport
à tout ça est donc dans l'article en
question
l'historien parler de la grippe
espagnole et expliqué que les
comportements étaient exactement les
mêmes c'est à dire y avait des gens qui
mettait à profit cette crise pour
s'enrichir et puis il ya ceux qui
faisaient tout ce qui faisait tout ce
qu'il pouvait pour aider les autres quoi
pour aider leurs proches
oui mais c'est je pense que dans tous
les cas si tu veux c'est l'essence même
de l'histoire c'est quand analyse
l'histoire ces procès de comprendre les
mécanismes qui en découlent de te les
approprier et si chaque situation est
différente on n'y a pas une réplication
d'un événement mais en tout cas il ya
des enseignements à en tirer et on peut
justement en ayant conscience de ce qui
s'est passé
essayer de tirer d être des meilleures
solutions des meilleures conclusions bon
avoir moi ce que je retiens de de
l'épidémie de grippe espagnole c'est que
a priori ce qui a été le plus meurtrier
s'est pas la première vague de
contaminations ça a été la deuxième est
justement ça il faudra faire très
attention au moment du des confirmands
et de ce qui va se passer après parce
que là si on tire pas les enseignements
de ce qui s'est passé à l'époque le
retour de bâton il peut être ultra
violent alors est ce que tu as vu ces
cas de super centenaires qui ont non
seulement survécu à la grippe estrella
918 à la seconde guerre mondiale et en
plus haut qu'au vide c'est quand même
extraordinaire a fait sourire mais moi
ça m'a fait penser à l'histoire que tu
avais développer sur le titre qui s'est
pris deux bombes atomiques quoi c'est
cette même acabit que c'est génial c'est
tellement incroyable bas donc là il ya
deux italiens il ya un italien et une
italienne qui ont connu la grippe
espagnole qui était évidemment pb à
l'époque de la cad espagnole en 1918
1919 qui ont deux fait survécu à cette
épidémie qui a fait des dizaines de
millions de morts et qui ont survécu à
une épidémie similaire en ampleur un
siècle plus tard c'est juste hallucinant
et je pense qu'il va y avoir je sais pas
si tu es d'accord avec toi mais je pense
que à l'issue de cette crise à l'issue
de ce confinement il va les voir une
quantité d'histoires à raconter
d'histoires individuelles un problème
ouais mais c'est cesser c'est clair et
net c'est clair et net façon on est en
train de vivre quelque chose qui qui
sera dans les livres d'histoire ça c'est
sur fond de teint moi je compte quand je
prends un peu de recul je me dis chatel
faisait 3 milliards d'humains qui sont
confinés au point que ça fait baisser le
bruit sous la terre c'est quand même
incroyable hasard qui attends moi
j'aimais 3 milliards de personnes qui
sont tous enfermés répit cc global quoi
c'est à dire que la gg j'ai bien un type
hyper sympa sacha qui vient en ukraine
et qui avec qui je corresponds de temps
en temps puisqu'il fait quelques sous
titres pour nota bene et donc on prend
des nouvelles
l'un de l'autre et tout à l'heure je
suis je disais bon bah et toi comment ça
se passe le confinement chez toi et du
bas nous ça se passe comme ça et tout
mais c'est incroyable c'est l'autre côté
de l'europe quand même on vit tous des
expériences un petit peu similaire est à
la fois très différente surtout globe
c'est c'est assez fou est ce que c'est
c'est sans précédent dans l'histoire un
confinement des 3 milliard de personnes
est ce que tu penses qu'on a déjà vu
quelque chose comme ça
enfin non enfin je dirais moi j'en ai
pas voilà je n'ai pas la science infuse
donc où l'histoire infuse mais mais non
je pense que c'est là c'est unique
ce qu'on est en train de virer s'alarme
m beaucoup de choses en question en
question sinon c'est sûr
sans doute ben il en reste 12 minutes
donc on va pouvoir aborder les
représentations culturelles je pense que
tu as pris quelques notes
donc est-ce que tu as vraiment étape
laisse dire que tu m'as tu penses tu
m'as dit de préparer quelques trucs
alors moi du coup ggg bon je ne suis pas
enflammé mille enfants j'ai quand même
fait trois parties alors catégorie films
j'en ai sélectionné trois un petit peu
différent voilà alors le premier c'est
un film que j'ai vu il ya pas très
longtemps le grand bain que je vais
louper au cinéma et puis finalement que
j'ai eu la chance de 2,2 d'acheter en
blu ray puis de regarder à la maison
donc part lelouch est une comédie
vraiment génial avec philippe katerine
notamment où on suit un groupe de type
totalement paumé qui décide de faire de
la natation synchronisée et donc on suit
ces types là qui sont totalement paumées
et c'est super drôle est aussi super
touchant et alors peut-être que c'est
moi plus je vieillis et plus je pleure
devant les films mais alors cela le
grand main à la fin c'était très très
dur de l'appareil
yamna plourde ou pas jeunes enfants oui
oui alors qu'à ça et c'est fou ok donc
le grand pin ouais ça c'est génial
dans un style totalement différent il ya
pas très longtemps non plus je me suis
enfin matt et john wick parce que tout
le monde me disait ça c'est génial
machin
c'est être sûr qu'au t1 et puis
finalement je suis allé dans un magasin
cash express ou tatouage de balle là je
me suis dit c'est la bonne occasion je
l'achète et je les regardais et je
trouve que c'est génial
les chorégraphies sont trop bien ça se
prend pas au sérieux et puis il ya quand
même un truc et moi que je trouve génial
c'est que d'habitude on fait la
connaissance du protagoniste sa famille
c'est de soutenir machin la merde lui
tombe dessus boon elle l'action c'est là
le truc c'est que le film commence mon
il arrive une merde aux protagonistes
mais on ne connaît pas le protagoniste
et on commence à le connaître par les
méchants ray tous les avec tous les
méchants qui dit à mon dieu mais on est
tombé sur ta logique et el hadj sady
mais c'est qui ce mec qui fait peur avec
la mafia dans tous les pays connaissent
des deux c'est génial
la montée en puissance comme ça être
très fort et en plus l'avantagé quand tu
quand tu as vu john wick c'est que tu
peux comprendre énormément de même qui
circule sur les réseaux sociaux de
barberousse chien de john woo notamment
par exemple par exemple qu'il ya un même
qui circule beaucoup on voit tas
d'ossements parfois cette annonce
parfois sept autres méchants mais donc
qu'ils sont qui sont dans le stress
total parce que ils ont touché aux
chiens de john wick réaliste que le
chien auquel ils ont fait du mal c'est
celui de jose mourinho
bon pour ceux qui ont pas je figurais
pas plus mais c'est vraiment les bons
central du film est aujourd'hui dans son
troisième épisode at il plus est ce que
je trouve intéressant avec john wick
c'est que il ya eu une phase avec les
matrix une phase de starification total
pour keanu reeves à l'époque des matrix
films les plus populaires de l'époque
ensuite je dirais pas qu'il ya eu une
traversée du désert mais c'est un petit
peu retombée il avec jodie meeks c'est
redevenu une des personnalités
populaires les plus les plus appréciés
sur internet quoi ouais ouais mais il
est bon plus fous et l'anglo dernier
film que je voulais conseiller c'est un
film qui est pas très récent non plus
mais de gondry on s'en fait en ce moment
on voit souvent jack black en train de
faire des conneries sur les réseaux
sociaux et moi ça me fait toujours rien
et donc j'ai repensé à soyez sympas
rembobinez
voilà et du coup je me suis dit si vous
avez l'occasion de le mater des gens
n'hésitez pas parce que c'est vraiment
un super film c'est une comédie où jack
black boys ou alors je ne sais pas qui
bossent dedans c'est qu'il est très très
fidèle à un vidéo club tous les vidéo
clubs ont fermé tout ça est en gros avec
son pote on est toute une histoire mais
il s'amuse à refaire des films des
classiques genre ghostbusters mais avec
vraiment pas d'argent quoi donc
ils refont buzz booster avec des trucs
en carton c'est absolument génial c'est
à mourir de hockey où est donc la cccd
film que tu va rattraper pendant gouët
wes ex-travailleurs de rattraper alors
nous a noté et ben écoute en syrie je
faisais du rangement comme tout le monde
et je suis retombé sur sur un blu ray
qui s'étaient égarés de mon coffret de
band of brothers et je me suis dit que
ça serait une bonne occase de houle a
conseillé aux 6,7 cette série donc c'est
une série qui a été fait en 2001 pas été
créée par steven spielberg et tom hanks
dans la foulée du soldat ryan puisque ça
n'a rien sorti en 98 et et du coup on
suit à travers une dizaine d'épisodes je
crois qu'ils font une heure chacun la
vie de la easy company donc qu'une une
compagnie donc notamment aéroportée du
début de la guerre jusqu'à la fin de la
guerre à ce qu'un pass est intéressant
c'est qu'on les voit vraiment sur tous
les théâtres d'opération c'est des types
qui ont été parachutés dans le cotentin
la veille du débarquement ceux des types
qui ont fait l'opération market garden
quand ils ont été parachutés de aux
pays-bas pour reprendre des ponts cdti
pkk ont libéré des camps aussi oulaya un
épisode qu'absolu longtemps et puis il
ya un épisode à bastogne dans les
ardennes
et ça ça m'a vachement touché parce que
- en plus ya pas très longtemps il ya à
peu près un an
un peu moins d'un an j'ai été tourné à
bastogne pour un projet en dehors de ta
bd et du coup j'étais dans ce bois
celle-ci compagnie était là et
même si bon le bois a été rasé par les
obus tout m'est donc ça à tous et il ya
quand même une ambiance un peu lourd
sinclair binage très fort et beaucoup
d'américains qui vont là bas et voilà
seul vraiment c'est la série est
magnifique les acteurs sont bien ces il
faut faut aller voir au niveau du
réalisme historique de la série
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que tu en penses
alors moi je suis pas assez compétent
non plus pour les trucs très pointu mais
honnêtement bas on suit quand même
différent type d'opération est ça le
mérite de pointer le doigt sur c'est sûr
c'est sur ces opérations là moi il ya un
truc qui m'a marqué c'est par exemple
lors de la libération du camp
il ya une scène très très dur où ils
vont libérer les prisonniers des camps
et et qu'en fait il ya déjà des vivres
qui sont à disposition et ils reçoivent
l'ordre d'empêcher les prisonniers qui
viennent de libérer de manger les
vivants tout simplement parce que si ces
personnes là qui crèvent la dalle depuis
des mois se mettent à avaler de la
nourriture en quantité industrielle
ils vont briller en fait tout simplement
et donc c'est pour leur bien et ça moi
je l'avais déjà lu dans quelques dents
quelques bouquins et le retrouver là
dans le dans la série à travers cette
mise en scène qui est juste la
bouleversante
bah ouais je trouvais ça c'est
intéressant parce que c'est un truc que
j'avais pas vu ailleurs par exemple
alors d'accord alors c'est carmen c'est
à ce que ce soit un secret pour personne
tu aimes le jeu tu aimes le bon jeu
vidéo est ce que tu en as a conseillé
oui alors mais là je vais pas être très
original parce qu'on est vraiment dans
l'actualité c'est à dire que non
seulement il ya animal crossing comme
moi tu leur as très bien puisque la fin
puisque on s'envoie des chapeaux
saucisses d'un sweat-shirt apaisé mais
juste un mois par rapport à des macros
singh c'est quand même un jeu
extraordinaire pour le confinement
parce qu'on peut continuer à voir ses
amis pas tant d'autres dans un monde
parallèle quoi et c'est une joie de les
retrouver des gens sur les îles
ça ne transportent vraiment vraiment
ailleurs c'est très chill d'intrigués
mais ensuite il ya tout mais eternal
parce que
voilà c'est moi j'adore j'adore doom et
puis c'est un fait mais pour moi c'est
aussi ultra détente mais c'est un autre
délire de détente c'est à dire qu'elle
va là dessus ces tutus jets dans l'arène
tu as des gros monstres du métal hyper
bouin du sang des tris pipe et puis tu
défonce tout et puis une heure après tu
es plutôt zen et puis en course y a en
plus vu que j'aime beaucoup de métal
balasy dedans est génial d'ailleurs il
ya des making of de de la bande
originale qui sont disposés sur youtube
avec comme il s'appelle mike celui qui
l'a fait je l'avais noté quelque part il
faut te donne est je sais plus mais que
dans la colonne mike gordon qui café la
bande son et qui a réuni un crew au fait
de gheest le chanteur de métal et café
une chorale de chanteurs de métal pour
dix ans et connaissent ouai c'est trop
bien ça et puis il ya la zone call of
duty qui sortirait pas très longtemps
qui alors moi pas j'aime pas trop club
de tir multijoueur est là pour un coût
j'adore et là on ils ont battu tous les
records même de fort night en l'espace
de trois jours ils avaient 15 millions
de joueurs enfin voila c'était
incroyable et le jeu est vraiment cool
ça permet de jouer avec des poteaux si
c'est un peu tactique
moi je j'aime bien c'est un peu un son
punk ska et un éclectisme rafraîchissant
parce qu'entre animal crossing et
warzone et doom de conclure voilà
enregistre un peu différent alors on a
une question qui remontait il nous reste
trois minutes on a encore un peu de
temps donc j'adore ton travail
as-tu pensé à une chaîne secondaire nota
bene junior tu t'adresses à un public de
classes élémentaires collégiens
alors pas trop j'ai une chaîne d'une
chaîne bonus qui s'appelle nota bonus
mais sur lequel je mets à des
commentaires de vidéos il ya des
conférences il ya pas mal de choses
après un truc dédié aux enfants
non c'est à dire que ça serait vraiment
intéressant de le faire et pour le coup
je serais pas contre du tout mais ça
demande du temps aussi et il faut pas
croire que la vulgarisation pour les
enfants c'est plus facile que la
vulgarisation pour les adultes
au contraire oui j'avais fait une série
justement de stands 2015-2016 que qui
est dispo sur la chaîne avec des petits
tampons kids sur les vignettes
il ya une dizaine d'épisodes essais des
épisodes qui sont adaptés à des enfants
qui ont entre 7 ans et 10 ans on va dire
donc peut-être que je leur ferai un jour
ça fait près trois ans je le dis mais
peut-être que je refais un jour voilà en
tout cas ces décès des trucs qui sont
intéressants je sais que ça manque de
programme pour pour les petits et c'est
intéressant
d'ailleurs je pense qu'on peut en
profiter pour citer cette chaîne qui a
été lancé d'ailleurs par renan l'otan
l'otan que le token qui tu travailles et
s'accompagne donc toi oui c'est de la
maîtresse part en live
ouais c'est ça c'est mary mary kay
lancer sa sachet de la maîtresse part en
live sur twitter sur youtube et c'est
tous les tous les jours de confinement
lundi mardi jeudi vendredi les jours
d'école à 15 heures il ya des programmes
justement pour les tout petits de
maternelle
voilà c'est une heure de live où on fait
des activités et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que chaque émission il donne la
fourniture de lait fourniture de ce
qu'il faut pour l'émission d'après pour
faire de la pâte à sel ou les tout comme
ça nous sont 100 blessés c'est plutôt
chouette voilà et si tu me permet
j'aimerais juste relaxé deux trois
conseils de bouquins parce que quand
même le passé ça peut être bien et puis
on peut les trouver sur internet aussi
en format numérique
il yad'abord sapiens une brève de
l'histoire de l'humanité que gg j'ai lu
il ya pas très longtemps de cheval noir
harry qui est vraiment un petit bijou il
ya les approximations historiques de nan
mais franchement c'est c'est génial bon
pour la suite il avait dit qu'on avait
un avantage de notre époque c'est qu'on
avait éradiqué les épidémies bon tant
pis y'a la bd les uns de fourbe que je
vous conseille vraiment parce que c'est
dans le délire aventures du nouveau
monde un peu l'eldorado le gars qui
passe qui par des basses classes qui se
dit je vais devenir riche et je vais
découpe me faire un nom dans le nouveau
monde et c'est assez génial
et puis il ya sacrées sorcières de
pénélope bagieu quand même ça c'est
vachement bien notamment pour les pour
les enfants moi je connaissais déjà en
fait les l'histoire de par un téléfilm
que j'ai découvert quand j'étais gamin
dans les années 90 qui s'appelait
sorcières et quand j'ai entendu ma femme
racontée le la bd aux enfants je me suis
dit tiens je connais cette histoire est
vachement bien à lire donc faut pas
hésiter à aller voir ça aime bien merci
beaucoup même pour des recommandations
merci pour ta présence cette émission
touche à sa fin
donc je remercie les abbés loup qui
étaient avec nous en première partie
je te remercie ben et je remercie avec
plaisir je remercie notre partenaire
assène ses talents sans qui cette
émission ne serait pas possible et je
rappelle qu'ils ont une plateforme sur
lesquels vous pouvez trouver tous les
films dispos en vod s'appelle vod point
cnc point fr c'est très pratique et nous
on se retrouve mardi prochain très très
bon week-end à tous
gros bisous j'espère que ça vous a plu
et à très bientôt
ciao eu lieu